we're not gonna be played okay we're
gonna hopefully make a deal if we don't
that's fine the United States in the
past was played like a fiddle money
going in and nobody knew what was
happening we will I think come up with a
solution and if we don't we leave the
room with great respect we leave the
room and we just keep it going
this isn't like past administration's we
don't play games joining us now Fox News
contributor retired lieutenant colonel
Alan West former Treasury Department
intelligence analyst Morgan Ortega's and
the author of Reaper former Brigadier
General Tony Tatum all right Allen I am
going to start with you I understand
that you were actually in the
Demilitarized Zone for a period of time
what is your take on the fact that Kim
jong-un has actually met with the
president moon of South Korea and
actually stepped over that Demilitarized
Zone was good to be with you judge and
in 1995 I was stationed there with the
2nd Infantry Division and I remember as
a senior officer seeing the tunnels that
the North Koreans had dug to try to
infiltrate into South Korea today was a
historical moment but we must understand
we have to keep the pressure on and Kim
jong-un has proven to be a person that
you cannot trust so we have to have the
systems and the sanctions in place we
have to be able to verify anything that
he says he is going to do because
history will teach us neverold
chamberlain sat down with adolf hitler
back in 1938 signed the Munich Accords
and then of course later on Adolf Hitler
said it was just a piece of paper and
worgen you know there are those who say
that we've reached a point now that that
has is is only due to President Trump
and he referenced it a few minutes ago
we said there was a lot of name-calling
and a few other things several months
back you know between Rocketman and all
the other back-and-forth but that really
did lead or create the foundation for
this meeting between president moon and
kim jung-han would you agree absolutely
judge I think that the president
deserves a ton of credit for what
happened today and you're even seeing
some of his biggest critics get
credit as well the South Korean
president went out of his way to say
that the policies that the president has
pursued is what has led towards today I
would say though that when you look at
what the general just said we view
everything with skepticism when it when
it comes to kim jeong-hoon but today we
saw for the first time the South the
North Korean leader step on his South
Korean soil we've never seen it before
and it's not just the rhetoric the
rhetoric is important it's the fact that
there is a credible threat of force
behind the rhetoric and I would add
judge that the historic sanctions that
nikki Haley and the Trump administration
pursued at the UN did deserve a lot of
credit because what happened was that we
caused pain in his pocket where it hurts
the most
so clearly one of the reasons he's come
to coming to the tables because of this
whole of government approach you have an
American president who the world
believes will take action you have
historic sanctions and I would add look
at what's happening with the Chinese
look the president is singing sending
his talk academic team next Jack to
China and the Chinese were part of this
because this is an opera hence of
strategy in East Asia general Teta let's
talk about the military component where
the president is indicated that he has
no reluctance whatsoever to use his
military option and and force to back up
and he's also not afraid to walk away if
he doesn't get what he wants from ken
Jeong on well judge I think the the
military component here is you know it's
peace through strength right we have
28,000 troops on the Korean Peninsula
and we've got you know the air force in
Guam and we've got you know we've had
three Carrier Strike groups in the Sea
of Japan surrounding the Korean
Peninsula with all of the air power that
comes along with that and tomahawks and
nuclear missiles that can be launched so
there's a credible threat from us to
North Korea that has been behind the
other elements of national power that
the president has artfully synchronized
here as we've talked before on your show
with the diplomacy information economic
all those elements of power and what
what you're seeing now is you know
success has a thousand fathers and
failures in orphan and so you know the
media is looking for somebody to dilute
the you know the praise away from the
president for doing all of these
and and so that you know they they
choose Kim jong-un's sister who was at
the at the Olympics and she may have
gone back to and talked to her brother
and said it's pretty nice down there you
know they have food you might want to go
check it out and but you know it's a
credible threat of military force and
president Trump is synchronizing that in
a very good way that has led to this
point and president Trump and his team
deserve the credit
Mike Pompeo deserves a lot of credit
well as a ambassador Haley okay and and
and so Alan I'm gonna go back to you you
know looking at Kim Jong on with the
president moon I mean you have to this
is a guy who was killing us six months
ago he was standing there with all of
you know with his toys of war and you
know did he have a lobotomy and me what
got to this guy that everything about
him has changed his body language has
changed were the economic sanctions that
that severe and is someone in this
country telling him hey you better make
this right or you're going well I think
it is as general Taylor just said when
you have a credible military threat and
the deterrent that backs up your foreign
policy just remember it was 2010 when
the North Korean sunk a South Korean a
naval vessel killing 46 of their sailors
and wounding another 56 and then later
on in that year in November 2010 there
was the North Korean artillery
bombardment of the South Korean island
and we said nothing we did nothing as a
matter of fact we continued to appease
and negotiate so for the first time we
have an American president that has
stood with resolve and resiliency but
also let us remember that the Kim
jong-un is responsible for the death of
an American citizen otto warmbier and
their three American citizens still
being held as well as Japanese citizens
so I understand him stepping across into
South Korea but this is a person that
has a very dark path past and has a very
evil intentions and we cannot put that
aside so we have to still proceed with
caution and and general Teta I mean the
the family has sued the North Korean
government of otto warmbier how is that
going to impact what is going on and
ensuing them does that have any any
chance of resolution in any way
well you know judge I think that it's a
holistic approach as we go into these
negotiations to try to get you know as
president Trump called it today this is
for the world and so we can we can scale
from you know a very important
microcosmic issue all the way up to what
we have to do for the world in a
denuclearized Peninsula Korean Peninsula
is so key to the world and and I think
the president and his team are going to
achieve that and and I believe that
they're going to achieve all the other
goals as well one of which is what you
mentioned
and-and-and-and morgan very quickly I
mean you know the idea of the large
armies that are actually on that that
border between North and South Korea the
fact that they might be able to come
home is certainly something to look
forward to it certainly is but I would
echo what the gentleman just said that
we need to lay out specific steps for
denuclearization what does it look like
how do we verify it we can and this
administration won't do this but we
can't make the same mistakes the Obama
administration and where they relieve
sanctions on Iran for a bunch of empty
promises that weren't fulfilled I know
this administration won't do that and
that's why we need to really verify that
this is going to happen well you know
what I I think all of us would agree
that the Donald Trump administration is
not going to create put together any
deal without real verification anyway
Alan Morgan and general Teta thanks so
much for being with us